I'm 37 married with no kids yet my net
worth is $1.1 million 600 in portfolio
500 in equity in my home which is worth
900 I make about $200,000 a year have no
Consumer Debt and have our three-month
emergency fund I just got into hunting
and there's several shotguns and rifles
I want but the misss doesn't see why I
need so many guns Uncle day being a man
of great means with many guns what is a
fair ratio he said I'm also about to
pull the trigger on a new lond Rebel L
is my first fishing and hunting boat
it's 39,000 out the door I'm paying cash
for it but would be pulling the money
from my portfolio to do so I feel it
passes the burn it on the floor test
what is your take thanks so much for
your time Sam the only thing I'll tell
you is is that there seems to be a a
ratio that every time I get a gun she
gets a new expensive purse there seems
to be a tradeoff there